on this episode that a Swiss boys stop
by
[Music]
[Applause]
in
this is
Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 258 of the askgaryvee
show and this has been one that's a year
in the making we have fun little
announcement for the vaynernation Big
Ups to everybody on Instagram Facebook
lives start putting in your phone
numbers we will be calling you shortly
setting be ready for that you can be
dialing in I love it but as you can see
we have two handsome gentlemen here with
me and and where I will frame this up
actually I'm going to let them introduce
themselves first we'll build up to this
moment and then we're going to let
Bharti tell a little story and then I'm
going to jump in give you guys before
well one of them we can do some calls
around the speaker business urban
culture marketing things of that nature
but why don't we start with better looks
go ahead my man Ivan Patrick Buchanan
the Global Marketing Director in case
with Patrick so what does that mean
exactly
I just make the world go round so when
did when it comes to case with like
everything every image you see every
influencer every celebrity we just
signed ence and announced that
partnership yesterday so that's
photoshoots and we have a team in Asia
and a team in Europe so it's a bigger
job at a fun one and the tell one have
you been there I've been in cages for
eight months so new ish newest yeah and
uh and have you always been in the
apparel sneaker world or or anything
like when your career start when you
first get into that yeah it's been nine
ten years now so I mean I started I went
to school for journalism they were
trying to pay me in nineteen K when I
got into college
I was like [ __ ] that and then I'm
hustling you know like online it made a
YouTube channel got a job in Virginia
got laid off the gaming of severance
Motel a needed an internship starting
and turning it Creative Recreation and
get every job its social media PR press
I just kind of looked to see like what
was going on and I just kept getting
promoted and from doing PR and celebrity
placements and it
being the marketing director and I did
that for five years and then I met
Barney and he brought me the case was to
change my life but it's not even you I
said I'm the president of k-swiss
and run the company run the brand's
based in LA yep I'm 20 20 some years in
the u.s. rigidly from England and 10 15
years in the sneaker game and so how
long have you been the president case
about a year and a half I've been doing
that so it's really a turnaround
situation yep
I sort of described it like a 50 year
old startup was founded in 1966 but you
know lost relevance over the years and
you know my job really is to try and
bring this brand back and that's really
what I'm focused on right now so let's
talk about the story of how the three of
us got here I think you get the credit
for the story so my two cents in a
minute but like let's talk about that
point yeah well I mean I I have to had
this nugget of an idea and for the brand
and how to really rebuild this brand and
it was really based around this idea of
entrepreneurship and this you know youth
aspirations changing and I've also a
kind of content junkie online I sort of
look at anything and everything that
goes where there's a cat video or or
whatever and of course so you can't
avoid garyvee if you're if you're really
looking at what's relevant online and so
yeah I was sort of became a follower and
just came to me one day like Gary's the
ultimate representation of what I'm
talking about the young people are
aspiring to be and so the beauty of
social media these days is you can
really reach anyone as long as you've
got a compelling you know pinch hook and
so I think I just went to the website
and did info apps you know I wrote an
info whoever that is and so and with a
new sentence banger you know and I
thought I'm cold email yeah yeah yeah
it's got to be good and it's got to be
short and sweet yeah and I got a reply
from someone of your team Gary replied
so DLX set up a meeting and then about
three hours later I got what an email
from you directly with just a smiley
face and that was it and I thought you
know that wasn't that was you basically
saying look I'm
would engage that I see it I mean I see
you know one thing that a lot of you may
know is I see a lot of the email that I
get and you know I'm 41 years old which
means I've watched sneaker culture
happen yeah I grew up when athletes
entered the parea being the face of it I
lived through before easy like when when
when Jay Z and others when hip-hop and
other in Run DMC really hit me you know
other things happen and I agree with you
as well and I've been living it and
seeing it that entrepreneur culture is
now a pillar of culture the way hip-hop
and sports is and so I smiled because I
set you know to me the things that I
want to be associated with and do um you
know like the Apple show or all the
stuff I do is if you hit it's meaningful
like Michael Jordan and easy and these
guys are in such a different level than
I am but look if entrepreneurs could be
faces of things you know
this is an early for a and sneakers a
matter so in an absolute pillar of our
culture to me the upside my smile was
the upside of being involved in
something like this or being part of
something like this could be interesting
and so then we met in LA that's right so
yeah we set up a meeting we met in and
yeah we had a meeting and I got an email
before I showed up hey fYI someone's
gonna be filming the whole thing which
oh yeah which is a little weird but I'm
like okay face I call myself face the
radio so but we did the meet thing you
know I love I always tells the stories
of Gary how you know you book meetings
by the minute so it's like the meetings
of five 23 until 528 and I think I
squeezed out another three minutes out
of you but yeah we told mine and it went
really well and I think it I was pushing
against an open door in terms of like I
was saying look here's how I see the
world and you were like absolutely and
you will live in it so I was so we're
preaching to the choir and so I think
they went from there for everybody on
Facebook Instagram if you're watching go
to Facebook if you want to put your
phone number and I think it's an
opportunity to talk about business
marketing streetwear holders cook
culture for sure I think the punchline
being everybody's watching at home I
think this is the right
to throw it up so from a caseless
standpoint I've decided to get involved
with these guys in the launch of a
generation K line behind us it's now on
their website some of you engaged on
Twitter some of you've seen me wear some
of them because I got a couple of early
advances and I've asked about it and so
that's kind of launching right getting
very close right now ish I would say
they're you know you guys are the
officials so and then we've got
something pretty secret coming in
November I think you're going to have to
be pretty not smart to be confused on
what it may be in November and I'm going
to make two recommendations right now
for the vaynernation I put an email as
GV sneaker right GB sneaker at
vaynermedia diagrams kind of give it
away sweeti sneaker at vaynermedia comm
there's two groups of you right now one
I highly recommend you put your name and
address and shoe size male or female and
then entitle you should put my shoe size
I think that's a good idea
I'll leave it at that and then for a
second group if you're a if you're a
speaker shop owner if you're an owner of
an Instagram account that plays in that
Street or but if you're influencer I
think when you email that we're probably
fast flashing now for the post on
YouTube I know this is live where I
don't know what you guys are doing right
now GB speak there at vaynermedia comm
if you're one of those kind of
characters or you think you can make
magic happen and some other way I'm not
thinking about in this environment or
through the CEO of target Brian Cornell
GB sneaker at vaynermedia comms send me
an email and title that is dead so we
can separate the two so that's my little
tidbit for that so very excited about
November excite that we're going to be
doing I'm going to be doing an
appearance of you we haven't figured out
the Pieta browser in August in LA so
you'll get information about that but I
think we should leave it at that for now
yeah I think we should open up the the
phone lines I would highly recommend and
appreciate the conversation within this
genre but obviously I'm always here for
use of whatever question you've got yeah
barn you did a really good job man as
you can imagine I get thousands of these
this is super interesting you've been
such a great creative partner and
marketing partner team cheering Tyler
I'm so proud of you there's some assets
hitting very soon that don't involve me
the entrepreneurial culture not
everything
see of a sneaker can represent the
culture I think speakers are doing that
now in all genres yeah
fashion is life is beverages are it's an
interesting time any this is you know
you're kind of seeing this with fresh
eyes pretty pretty interesting right
love it what are they saying on the
ground good vibes from it's not maybe
you can even look if somebody if you can
pin the email or if somebody can do that
on my team if they're watching you ready
go
I mean go ahead it done min-jung man
love it I
while Steph is dialing what were you
doing prior to being the president
peaceless well actually I was working
been in the sneaker business awhile I
was a human for a long time in Boston
and I ran marketing a puma in North
America and I rebuilt a brand called
palladium palladium boots and ultros
military boom in its garyvee and ran
askgaryvee show with the case with mafia
wow that that is crazy are you from
after loss Syracuse New York I love it
what's your question and so I was just
wondering how are you guys going to
reinvent k-swiss I mean I've heard of
the case quiz I love case with but it
hasn't been around for a while now yeah
especially with Yeezy it's like the
crack of our shoes you know how do you
know yeah make this happen I mean I mean
yeah I mean looking a it's definitely
that's that's the ultimate question yes
a little cool Gary Vee but I've always
really believed if you can't be first be
different and the sneaker market is
dominated by massive strong companies so
the first thing I said is you can't be
the fifth best that what they're already
doing okay so in other words Nike owns
the idea of athletic so if you want to
run a six-minute mile or you get up in
the morning want to dunk a basketball
wear Nikes adidas now owns this position
of celebrity so you want to be the cool
kid of the party where adidas and that's
nicely differentiated from Nike so I
knew you know worst thing I could do is
try and be the 10th best Nike or the
10th best adidas so I said look there's
really a
not just me as a group of his birth is
really a new aspiration so if a
celebrity made the athlete look
old-fashioned I think the entrepreneur
or the young CEO is making the celebrity
look old-fashioned because the new
aspiration of people is to have their
own company to be the boss to be have a
brand not to to run a six-minute mile I
mean any but everyone I talk to says you
know if I give you a choice you won't
play for the Yankees you want to do a
concert or you want to be the CEO of
your own company
I think 60% said CEO so this scheme
changed because the greater to that 10
years ago was 0 min I think you know
from my standpoint even think about you
know the fact that you're watching
they're calling into this show right
what what fashion brands and definitely
sneakers since I think they're at the
top of the pedestal now of culture have
to do is trade on culture sports was
culture hip-hop and music is culture
it's really wild to see entrepreneurship
emerges culture and I think Barney's
betting on that does that make sense men
I mean I'll give you an example somebody
else who's got a fashion brand or a
sneaker right now may say you know what
I'm going to go all-in on eSports
celebrities and I believe that if I get
the 40 biggest eSports fans to love my
brand that all the kids that look up to
them it's there's nothing new here it's
are you good enough to trade on what's
emerging is the basic bet here right
like like it's not the game is the same
I'm you can go back to John Wayne
smoking a cigarette there Lucky Strikes
you're siphoning off of culture I think
Barney's vet is is entrepreneurship big
enough look I'm not [ __ ] easy or Kobe
so the good news is for them they're not
paying me anywhere close enough any of
that [ __ ] so it's it I think the
question becomes first of all I think
this is what Patrick a like and the
design team they had to upgrade their
designs the big thing I ask them is like
look if I'm going to be involved with
this I need to be able to want to wear
it do they look good I think that was a
big play for you guys
and they're going to make a bet on
whether it's me or the other people
they've got they've got other people
signed and associated can they hack
enough of entrepreneurship and this
being a sneaker that associated with
Omaha sir I'm an entrepreneur
will that be fruitful enough to trade
that the
was worth the growth in sales because it
hacked culture it makes sense yeah makes
sense so it's really a mindset you know
it's a different voice is the same
person who's who were all talking to
it's a question of are they more
receptive to listening about sports
celebrity or entrepreneurship and so
it's about finding white space which is
true of any business or any brand is you
know don't push against a closed door
find an open one and be the first at
something versus the 10th and that's
really a min about it may not work right
like I think the thing that's really
interesting is that a lot of people said
that celebrities couldn't endure
sneakers for a long time in the game
especially over in it because and you
saw it not work a lot of times evening
some of the biggest non athletes
celebrities struggled to get any
traction but now that Easy's happen and
Rihanna's people say is it now it's like
just seems like normal yeah I mean I
don't know if this is going to work it's
not work I just believe that this is the
best at-bat and for me the failings I
did the Apple show I want to be involved
in first if this works and it becomes a
big time speaker and all the way
entrepreneurs wear it I win if it
doesn't work I win and let me explain
why I want to win for these guys I'm
going to win at the with what I signed
up for I always do this I've already
delivered for them I if it doesn't work
when I'm 58 it's a funny joke on stage
right like remember when I thought I
could do a sneaker like it just win win
I mean I think that's a really important
thing for everybody watching putting
yourself in positions that a win win are
extremely important got it
hey I got it cool man thanks for calling
thank you I can't wait I think I can't
wait until to see what you do with this
Brandon it's really exciting I'm gonna
watch closely how long have you been
paying attention to me good six months
good so then maybe you do or don't know
this but like my aspiration for building
vaynermedia was to buy iconic brands and
remark it to them so for me this is a
great little middle step to associate
with guys I ended up really liking a
brand that I knew is I mean I knew
tasteless when I see was rocking and
what [ __ ] was gangster right so like
like it's an iconic brand that has a
chance that we've seen iconic brands
work and not work
I mean d-box learning Stan Smith like
that
rebooted through a similar one so it's
really just going to be I agree with you
I'm I'm more interested in watching it
then almost merely being in it yeah I'm
offended by derail where it is no emails
Amy I notice you are sticking it to your
face maybe we should play fanatically
how about that because on HSN if you
want to talk about thanks minutes other
guys get a [ __ ] rock I sent you so
many packages so besides the rock being
a terrible human being I what has been
interesting so actually taking back can
I ask this question even want to know
why the Sean Carter's did not work I
feel like okay give me your job s why
I'm in your purse and not whether this
is true enough from your opinion why did
they not work when does it happen when
was that 2002 early 2000 okay why did
that not work
I think the difference between even this
partnership and that partnership is that
it has to feel authentic you know and I
think you're just doing it for money can
you just join up for money and he didn't
did he wear the shoes did he did you
really talk about it's a difference
between Yeezy and Rihanna is every ohne
worte shoes every single day this is
taking you can dial it up this is taking
uh let's get to this I don't really see
anything that you can't you guys off
guard I want you to tell the truth
because it's going to be value to them
yeah hello Jesse this is Gary Vee and
you're on the askgaryvee show with the
case whisk room what Josie what's up
well how you do Jess I'm doing great how
are you guys good what makes you a
question my question was I wanted I
created a podcast I mold for two parts
number one I used to resell Snickers on
eBay starting when I was like nine years
old mom so I wanted your guys advice on
how like teenagers and kids who are
interested in entrepreneurship and
business and um choose to sort of get
into that market what you recommend a
lot of teams to do well so aren't so I
mean you the way you get in is figuring
out ways to get access to the best [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] flip it it's like
there's nothing you need to do other
than have money and either wake up
earlier [ __ ] make relationships or find
information that other people don't have
to get the thing right this is a
multi-billion dollar industry by the way
at this point so this
how old are you now just I'm sixteen and
now I run a podcast EXO yeah have a
meeting with you in a couple weeks I
call the emails into a meeting so that's
amazing and number two since you were
selling seven years ago you know the
problem with this week so the great
thing with the speaker game now is the
markets bigger than ever but there's
also more people in it than ever that
are trying to get access to these things
you know look I think you got to make
that you know for example AJ bought
pairs of balls sneaker on the bed of
like it'll be worth something maybe one
day seven years from now I think
flipping in the short term look I
actually think the thing that we're up
to in the thought like one of the
funniest things I like oh I need to save
a bunch because if I end up being but I
think I'm gonna end up being is like
like this will be worth money in 13
years so I think you've got to make
long-term bets is one thing that I
recommend kids are in the sneaker game
and number two it's all about
relationships
all about really getting access to the
hot products because you know there's
never enough so someone always wants it
and I mean I think if anything showed it
was this recent supreme Louie Vuitton
drop t-shirts are now reselling on eBay
at for four to six thousand dollars so
you know there's an Nvidia there's
multiple assess one thing I'll give you
credit for is the thing that we're up to
November Kappa you've been trying to
make the numbers lower even though I
know we can sell more yeah and so
there's just interest you know just
interesting exactly better to sell out
and have little experience of the moment
and I'm never bad thing and I highly
recommend you send me your shoe size and
Saddle River address and email to that
email I put up in the beginning of the
show oh you know I will man that I'll
talk to you soon I'll see you soon - bye
well thanks a lot bye-bye I'll stay on
24 can't wait so we're going to see him
on the 24th before you can get to set up
Seth but where I was going to go back to
authenticity have you two spoken with
each other about how ridiculously I am
all in
given the economics you guys gave me
yeah yeah yeah I'm actually good I think
right well you know you put you know let
the deeper that's the thing I'm going to
do a partnership I'm going to go
completely all the other way and I
always
worried about people because I'm the
cynic of the group so every time we have
one of these yeah I didn't know you are
no I remember can I and I'm like I
thought I was like no no as we've gone
over this time you're probably out of
all the people that I've ever worked
with have delivered the most already and
we haven't even done the thing yeah I
mean it's an you know you billet you
won't believe how hard it is sometimes
to get simple things done that we
incidentally I know yeah I see have you
imagined word though I think that's more
important I think that I can say you're
going to do something you mean so many
of you like I'm the greatest thing that
every good night and I'm like I can't
believe it because I've had so many
people tell me that I mean how's it work
yeah the other big factor here is that
sneakers are now part of the uniform of
business you know look at you jeans
t-shirt sneakers the basis I think it
was Peter Thiel that said never trust
anyone in businesses wearing a suit
because it's like that is the [ __ ]
uniform it's realizing then you don't
know this two three years ago I had a
similar opportunity I only react to
reality I didn't think three years ago
an entrepreneur sneaker played because
it hadn't fully done there yet now it's
the only thought like it's nobody under
35 thinks any other way but it's parent
raised even higher you're getting people
that abhorrest suit and tie their whole
careers now going into that culture
anybody under 30 watching without won't
even think twice is encrusted dress
shoes get the [ __ ] out again
who's this no Anna South are not not
here okay Barney's learning material is
it Anna see mr. chance
hello Anna it's Gary B you're on the
askgaryvee show and you're here with the
case Swiss guys probably [ __ ] I cannot
believe it you are through we're here in
Connecticut are you from Anna I am a
free from Dan Mary I love it how are you
tonight I'm great man I can't even read
them on the phone right now how are you
guys super doing it with your question
so I currently am a photographer out
here in Connecticut um kind of like you
know sold the dream of like you know go
to New York and like
all your [ __ ] and you know just can be a
photography but I really just want to
pace myself from where I'm from and I'm
kind of having a hard time like getting
clients that I just print I think having
a hard time when branding myself so I
want to get your two cents on how I even
start with that because I know that
there's so much social media get more
than one thing in a life cheap you have
two questions how old are you and why do
you want to plant your flag in Danbury I
am 22 right now and I want to plant my
flag in Denver because I see a lot of
people that are just so talented out
here and I really want to get their name
out I want to help other people grow - I
don't want it to see what because me
don't know when you kill Diana Lee the
main reasons you can help you can help
anybody anywhere like that has nothing
to do with the physical location you're
at right managers erection I just found
a lot of my friends right I just have a
lot of friends I want to expose to be
honest mean let me then I want on
awesome yeah I mean you can't help
others until you help yourself
right like one of the great mistakes of
the young hustlers that I talk to right
now is they're so altruistic and either
they're completely full of [ __ ] and want
to say no [ __ ] up front but really
what they mean is they're selfish or
they actually just genuinely mean it but
the advice for both groups of those
individuals is the same which is you're
not helping anybody
until you've created a foundation right
I've been able to help so much you know
what I'm doing now why I have an
audience is I've been able to help so
much but I didn't help [ __ ] the first 13
14 years of my career I put my head down
and [ __ ] work to create a foundation
for me to be able to help you know to be
very frank for me it's far more likely
that you do go to New York
do your thing for three years you're 22
eat [ __ ] live in a ghetto craigslist
apartment with 11 [ __ ] people in a
studio in [ __ ] Harlem right get on
get that photo that made it happen
meet people because the amount of [ __ ]
that happened in New York since you and
I were on this phone together is 50
times greater than what's going to
happen in Danbury
get the next [ __ ] mother I'd say the
kids of the ography the Peter pataga
really is is access where you are
because everyone's a photographer now
it's not about who pushes the button
better it's who's in the right place and
that's key I think there was a guy
called Ricky Powell he's a famous sort
of hip hop street photographer and he
wasn't a better
it wasn't about his photography skills
on twisting the lens it was the fact
that he was in every show and the front
row in every side alley capturing every
moment and his skill was being in the
right place is accessed and not his
buttons he was pushing yummy good that's
all when I say your network your network
is your net worth
yes if you don't have a network then you
don't have anything pretty much yeah I
mean I think you know and I think I
think you're going a little altruistic
it's very I think you happen to be a
nice person who met nice people in
Danbury Connecticut I would like to see
them be successful great this is about
so much more
a that is true but I also want to make a
living off of this and I want to I want
to be able to make money out of my
passion so well that would mean why you
should get in New York and not stay in
[ __ ] Danbury yeah and if you get paid
off of a good Instagram feed these days
I mean it's never been easy to make
money up by being a good and wonderful
do you have a romance of the narrative
of like you made it in Danbury are you
scared of New York like help me here I
I'd love to make it in New York to be
honest like I don't I don't go down
bright over New York okay okay so what's
stopping you from that be able to afford
it yeah good to be honest and like the
odds of like financial yeah you need to
go to New York and get a [ __ ] job
for eight hours a day Lynch on this [ __ ]
and then spend the other eight hours a
day that you're awake working on your
craft and the need to wake up at 29
years old and have a prayer of it
actually happening and yeah and d-roc on
Tyler and Eddie are all smiling these
are all guys that have worked for me for
a while and that's what they did and
that's why they're smiling wow thank you
so much guys you want I have a question
to listen when I do
New York can I serve you maybe I don't
wanna make any promises but here's
always saying I mean II work and and be
in New York one year later and prove it
to me
and then you can choose me perfect okay
now is that they're the biggest reason
so many people at 22 aren't winning is
because they're fancy like you can live
in New York you just need to live in the
suburbs of Manhattan like the outer of
Manhattan and you need to eat [ __ ] you
need to work at Target in Queens for
seven hours a day so that you can afford
roommates in shitty Queens right and I
love Queens is when I first came to in
America I'm not dissing on Queens city
blend anyway
live somewhere shitty with a lot of
people and eat [ __ ] food with healthy
and and [ __ ] grind that's all right
now imma do it I get it guard good luck
this is the thing like this is the thing
this would be the you know and this is
you know what I'm going to use this as a
cool tie in this is what brands try to
figure out if God willing I use god
forbid as a slang term for God willing
it's God willing your brand can
represent that energy to people that's
why you have a little where it yeah
right
yes but does she care about running a
six-minute mile today or trying to get
ahead in life that's my whole point
you took your money you're right like
goodness you're right right bad knees we
may not execute yeah
absolutely that's what it comes down to
100% you're right you might have picked
the wrong guy to so say with you might
have picked the wrong designed and I
have the wrong distribution deals but
you're right somebody's going to win it
yeah yeah news is the early early
predictions is there it's working so
like when we went to action and shoe
palace and all these accountants it's
going to be in those doors come August
so let's take me by hey we're doing it
when I was at this point when you said
when you talk about you know
entrepreneurship and you've been the
voice of that who's an end it's
undeniable
the buyers really bought into everybody
disputes it because it's true so why are
we talking about focus group through
this Gary B here on the askgaryvee show
[ __ ] yeah yeah good question man you're
here with the case risk guys yeah so
how's it going guys
so Cerullo coming from come on 24 dr.
Prasad and I started in small agency
went freelance for about a year and then
just recently jumped on to a different
smaller you can see where I like the
culture better I like the guy that
specifically working working with and
learning from and I want to map my
career into like the VC angel investment
world but and but kind of where I
struggled over the last year was there's
a lot of things that I need to learn and
need to be able to stomach and build up
in my own confidence before I can really
jump into the entrepreneurship and tell
my ideal question Gary do you think that
that is a different skill set on the
entrepreneur side that goes into the BC
angel investment side so are you asking
me do I think there's a different
skillset and mindset from an
entrepreneur versus somebody who's an
investor in entrepreneurs correct I do
let me ask you another question
you're in Cincinnati working at an
agency a marketing agency yes small
strategic do a lot of go to market
starts did it they've built in the
nameless startup in the startup
enterprise yeah and our enterprise kind
of arrangement to go to market kind of
rough and you think at this point you're
young man that you want to be a DC for
angel investor yeah I want to get I want
to get into the more high-level strategy
side of of helping great products great
ideas great great entrepreneurs get the
market I feel like for me personally my
I think I've got what you were your
purchase entrepreneurial pending yeah
but I think I'm still learning to
navigate whether I
eminence have the personality has a
personality to be the to be the one
lonely guy the top personality trait to
be the entrepreneur at the top is an
unbelievable self belief and not give a
[ __ ] about the world and you've got to
be a little bit delusional practicality
hurts entrepreneurship a lot of times
because it's so hard and lonely and
insular and and and and high-risk and
you have to love losing more than
winning which is not a lot of people's
traits because they're posturing to the
outside world social media has taught us
that people will PR themselves
everybody's the greatest on social media
that's an indicator right like even
notice you know is funny when I start
getting on snapchat my natural tendency
was to take ridiculously poor with
pictures of myself on planes looking
like [ __ ] because of that that was like
losing an entrepreneurship while
everybody else was staging private plane
bottles motley it's just so funny the
insight so I think I think even it's
even listening to you in two seconds I
think you know that you're not
necessarily an entrepreneur so I think
you're barking up the right tree here's
what I would say similar to Anna make
sure you get a heavy dose of New York LA
in San Francisco afford to be able to go
out there go to conferences you can get
really caught being in a smaller market
because you're playing at a minor league
level and and and to really be a
successful VC or angel investor
especially in my opinion in the next ten
years when I predict the downfall of
that market once there's a correction
you're gonna have to be really special
or you'll be looking for another job in
four years so keep that in mind okay
yeah absolutely yeah take care of good
luck if there's any more in if there's a
sort of theme of all the young
entrepreneurs we speak to because we
speak to a lot and up in sort of
generating products of stuff like this
is is struggle I means no glamour in in
in the store in the back stories you
know and and there's definitely more
failure than success in the
in my life everything every day 95%
Academy it's not even like two nuts I
think people were watching generally
leaves like every other person wins like
the reaction and the buy because it's
been put on this pencil and because it
is cool now like almost everybody is
going to lose almost every single into
the Romo Calais now that says
entrepreneur will lose time and your
money and your reputation it's do you
get cop off so here's what happen a lot
of these people are losing money they're
raising a little bit of money because
their uncle thinks they're the next Mark
Zuckerberg well kids don't realize is
they're losing time and reputation when
they try to force themselves to be
entrepreneur and that's why we see so
many fake entrepreneur for now doesn't
cost any money to come up with a funny
name printed on a t-shirt and say that
you're a fashion entrepreneur makes no
money
what you're losing is the winners of the
world think you're a joker and you never
recover right what you're losing is you
spent three years on your [ __ ]
t-shirt business and we could have been
doing was learning skills by interning
somewhere around what you're good at
self-awareness is the key to great
entrepreneurship we'll see we did a guy
yesterday who had a sock business as I
called my chairman is first Randy made
80,000 pairs of socks and they were
faulty he had to eat 80,000 years oats
and all I thought was how did you go
back to order another 80,000 you did
failed once you to go back and and say
I'm going to go the second time that's
the gene that you if you don't have it
you're kind of wasting your time my
biggest fear of this entire project is
that this really works super well and
people think that wearing these sneakers
they're an entrepreneur that you'll
probably just find that I'm [ __ ]
petrified of like you've got to do the
work yeah yeah
lastly reservoir ready bridge Britney
from Florida all right
get clear it's really nearly 80-thousand
you know how many people would have
given up and said you know one forget
and got even funnier up Brittany this is
Gary Vee and you're in the askgaryvee
show with the case whisk guys how are
you oh my god I'm about to die right now
I know I am I know would be brief
awaiting system so what do you have a
question yes so I just wanted to know as
far as like with the case was bland are
you guys planning on making the speaker
accessible like I feel like with
sneakers that are really starting to pop
like Adidas and even especially with
Nike for a while people that really want
them can't buy them and then it just
kind of gets oversaturated on like eBay
and then you know small sneaker stores
that sell $150 shoes for like 500 bucks
and it's really sucks for a person I
really want to buy sneakers and
collectors yeah I mean I'll let these
guys speak to the overall thing but my
main plan for November is I'm going to
buy them all and then trade them for a
thousand a pair on eBay so I'm going to
make them really not accessible
interesting somebody should I mean I'm
kidding I'm kidding is right okay I'm
kidding
got yeah I look I think first and
foremost you know we're not we don't yet
have the cachet where we can have people
lining up and for one little limited
thing you know
oh yeah we're a sneaker for everybody
we're not trying to be the niche little
streetwear brand I guess we're trying to
build a big media company for everyone
so but you know there are some realities
but for supply and demand about you know
do you free by you know ten thousand
pairs and then find out only a thousand
people are interested in them and you've
now got nine thousand pairs in the
warehouse so I think you know there is a
limited audience a very dedicated
voracious audience who collects these
higher-end things and so you know
there's that there's a balance between
ordering the right amount and then not
making them so scarce that everybody's
left disappointed and it's been is
created this huge aftermarket I think
for us we'll make things accessible as
we can
we've talked a lot about this Gary and
asked about you know what is the demand
going to be and I don't think we've
really got the answer yeah I'm not sure
I mean so I think but I think the
question becomes this happened in the
wine business
it was interesting one of the things I'm
watching sneakerheads go through is you
know do you really want that sneaker or
do you want that sneaker because it's
hard to get right like it what happens
is things become caricatures of
themselves I think we're about to go
into and one of the reasons this was
interesting to me is I think we're about
to go into the genre where people are
getting more self-confident confident
about their sneaker game and so when I
see somebody only wear limited-edition
sneakers I genuinely mean what I'm about
to say I look at them and I go back to
you're insecure like that that they need
write to me to me I like want to rock
like a pair that you could buy at the
dollar store to mix with the $1,400
you know resold pair of sneakers so I
think the question becomes to you is
what kind of sneaker you know gal head
are you right do you you know you know
what's that mix cuz I you know you know
what happened in fashion right people
are now wearing you know and the
high-end $4,000 handbags with eight
dollar t-shirts and $9,000 glasses I
think we're going to start seeing the
most secure sneaker heads start really
[ __ ] mixing it up right like common
common Grauman's shoe that you could
find in [ __ ] Walmart they just like
the way it looks for 18 bucks I'm gonna
rock that Tuesday Wednesday I'm gonna
rock a one of one limited edition
$90,000 thing that you can only buy if
you milk the cow in Japan it's only Gary
right break any sneaker that I'm
actually gonna buy I'm going to make
sure that one is comfortable and to that
I mean it's not ridiculously price like
I'm 35 and I got bill collectors and
people kind of like Scott for me or
whatever but whatever I do launch it but
like if case which is going to like come
back with Dominion spiking dope styles
and a comfortable I'll totally buy them
like I'm not all like you know I love
these Balenciaga sneakers for $1400 and
like that's more than my mortgage that's
crazy you know that's exactly right well
lucky for you check and check their
comfort
and affordable yeah those things sell
out by the way at forty hundred bucks is
amazing yeah I think we're branding is
important I think you know when people
put brands on themselves especially
young people in fashion it says a lot
about who they are mostly born we want
the world think of them yeah exactly and
so you can't under appreciate what that
means and I think there's you know a
safety in fitting in I mean everybody
wants to fit in which drives a lot of
people to buy the brands everybody else
buys there's a certain type that isn't
burdened by that you know that Nene and
and there's also and then another level
of people say I purpose you want to do
something different and those are the
people right now that are starting to
reach out to us and said hey I want to
be the first people on k-swiss
not the thousandth person on Brand X
it's already in every store so Brett if
you did you email the GV sneaker at zero
Mediacom yeah well I'll put it in the
wrong thing but I'm going to definitely
know you now do as I say thank you so
much for everything Gary likely received
like inspiring so much with um just all
your content seriously I appreciate you
so much dude that means a lot to me can
you please do me a favor when you ve
mail that email now can you put Britney
from Florida in there that I called in
because I want to pull that one out I
got something for you
absolute thank you so much the reference
oh crap like that Taylor Smith I need
that but I need your shoe size but don't
fool around
oh and a dress yeah 11 min to 11 is our
big ticket all manager send it over talk
you sorry all right this is fun man yeah
here in the meeting you yeah again are a
ticking away ticking away so anyway a
lot more coming get ready for November
I'm really excited about what we got
going on but really LA date in August
August first
okay show me I was on Melrose oh you're
really dropping in Bobby's first LA
coming to see la complex Conan event but
a big day for us on the calendar lookup
complex con Long Beach I lock in for
that that's firm firm firm um speaker
like we're locked in
okay case with Gary be the surprise is
so we did I talked to mark experience
to fit me doing alright right I don't
need to speak to be there okay we'll
figure that off anyway the question of
the day you guys get to ask the question
of the day this is as good of an
opportunity for you to get market
research on entrepreneur mindset around
speaker culture so I would ask a very
very detailed needle in the haystack
like questions you will get thousands of
answers on Facebook in YouTube do not
blow it Barney I would ask look I would
ask what is the real need of a
entrepreneur in terms of a sneaker and
footwear you know what is it that is
there something that's missing or what
are the real needs that people have the
weekend weather removing so there's
another thing yeah and it might be
versatility I'm paid you know things
like I'm I get up at 6:00 I get home at
10:00 I go to the gym the office and a
meeting I need something that works for
everything I fly I need something
packable like and what is it so because
I think the more that we create products
that fit real needs is it was so much a
most able to do with the contract at the
sneaker course yeah like I think it's
the emotional thing William from an
authenticity simpler where does it show
up you know what are you a speaker like
like you know like you know like there's
only so much you can do with this
like I mean look if you can [ __ ] in and
do some [ __ ] and I travel but like it I
think it's you know I think I think we
need to be realistic and fair no speaker
in the world can do anything but other
than I mean there's clearly some
technologies or trading on that thing
that connects that audience to is the
[ __ ] game yeah all right nice
experience show me thank you Gary
it already thank you you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
you